hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on Florida and Ubisoft just
released a new trailer on the Ubisoft
website called for on or year three a
year of the Harbinger deep dive and
we're gonna talk about that and show
what and show some of the stuff that's
in the trailer and some tidbits of info
on what might be coming next year or
next season so let's get straight into
the video as always like to be if you do
enjoy subscriber for new I cover the
informational side of foreigner that
being balanced changes here are updates
patch notes and leaks let's get started
they basically stated in the beginning
that they added ten new heroes two new
game modes lots of other content from
very beginning in the game two years ago
but the first notable point of
information is that here's a little
quick bit of a small showcase of the new
map the new Dominion map for season 9
called harbor looks really nice and
small and I cannot wait to play this you
can see on the far right that there's a
white border so that's probably one of
the spawn points either being a or C for
the flags and Dominion that's what I'm
assuming at least I may be the ship in
the middle could be B I have no idea
actually but this is gonna be a really
fun map it seems very small compared to
the other map so this could be pretty
hectic I'm very excited for this let me
know what you guys think about that
after that they showed some of the
customization options for the black
prior hero and specific they first
showed off the helmets such as the one
on the screen right now we got some
skull masks some really edgy looking
masks as well the character
customization on this guy is gonna be
absolutely top tier I cannot wait to
play this guy next they also showed a
little bit of the armor and weapons they
these are most likely going to be in set
so the armor and the weapons on the left
are most likely gonna have the same name
but I could totally be wrong not
entirely sure I love the horns in this
edgy mask that they keep showing off I'm
getting this weird Diablo vibe did the
game Diablo so if anyone any of you guys
have played the album maybe you can back
me up on this but I'm getting like a
weird Diablo vibe from this these
helmets so but that's just even more
exciting next is a better look at the
shield from the middle image as a big
skull with two red eyes which is most
likely jewels or gems with the weapon on
the left looking very similar as well as
the curved handle and some skull and the
same skull on the handle as well with
the two red eyes going back to the image
we have the armor set on the left and
this is a standard looking shield but
has it looks like it has scales in the
middle with a big snake curling in the
front it's got this weird type of
serrated side to the edge of the shield
looks really nice and I actually I
actually preferred this one more than
the one on the middle personally to me
but I actually got its mostly because of
these scales in the middle looks really
nice and clean the helmet could be
better
but it's whatever though I don't really
but mind it too much for the image on
the right we actually can't really get a
good look at the shield sadly but it
does seem to have like a serrated type
edge very similar to all the other
shields the sword you also really can't
get a good look as it's sideways this is
a really poor image so like we can't
really dive deep into this one but these
shoulder pads are looking real crisp put
some nice detail and this little goblin
looking guy in the elbow the mask can be
a little bit better I like the hood I
really don't prefer the metal part at
the top but still a solid piece and then
the less they're also focusing on
updating the faction more to make it
look more engaging and fun maybe we
actually get to fight people for
territories not entirely sure what
they're thinking is but I'm long game if
we get to make this a little bit more
fun and they also want to focus on their
number one priority for the game which
is always gonna be bouncing and changing
up new characters and old characters
this for example like shougo key and lob
ringer and then following up a PK in
warlord my bets is that long burger and
shougo ki are going to be getting in
something in season 9 because listen how
they say it real quick character
balancing starting with the Tsubaki
bringer and continuing with wallah is
keeper and so on
they say continuing with warlord in PK
as basically saying that you go key and
law burger are gonna be first then
followed by PK and warlords so my bet is
law burger is going to be getting some
type of buff or change next season but
maybe I'm looking too far in this I'm
not entirely sure on top of that they of
course want to fix targeting reaction
time and revenge which is also a really
good start for the year let me know what
you guys think about the new black prior
armor in the comments down below it now
today is Wednesday tomorrow is gonna be
Thursday is that's gonna be the dev
stream day I'm most likely going to be
seeing this armor already if not maybe
even more armor so no worries I'll
definitely recap that tomorrow but let
me know what you guys think about the
armor that we just saw
especially the harbor map or the Shikoku
River possible the law bringer buff
possibility anything about this video
let me know your thoughts and what you
guys are most excited for for season 9
in the comments below
and without elective if you do enjoy
subscriber for new I cover the
informational side of foreigner that
being bounced changes here updates
passion notes and leaks so if you want
to get kept up today with everything
happening in the world of water
definitely stay subscribe to the channel
and with that my two most recent videos
would be on screen if you guys do want
to check that out with the guys so mr.
dick Forks in the video and peace out
[Music]
you